Movies. We all love them, we all watch them,
and sometimes they change our lives.
Mostly they don't, but sometimes they do, and here
are some of the ones that did for me.
Number 1: Spider-Man. It's not a perfect film.
It's not even the best
Spider-Man film, but when I saw it, it was the first
time that I ever experienced
Spider-Man's origin story, and it was that which
cemented him as being
my favorite superhero. As a kid, I loved Spider-Man
because he was just
really cool, and I spent literally years of my life
fantecizing about having all of his powers.
Pretty standard, really. As I grew up, however,
I realized that the reason I liked Spider-Man so
much was because he was just
the most relatable superhero for me.
He's given this great power
that he doesn't ask for. He instantly goes out and
uses that power for personal gain,
and it's only after his arrogence catches up with him that
he then decides to go and use his power for good.
Maybe it's weird for me to relate to the
character so much, but I
never felt like I asked to be charlieissocoollike.
It's just something that's kind of
happened to me, and now that it is who I am,
I do feel a responsibility
to try and use that for good as opposed to just
using it for myself,
and, of all people, Spider-Man was the one who
taught me that.
Number 2: Jiro Dreams of Sushi. So this is a
documentary about an 85-year-old
sushi chef called Jiro that my friend Mickeleh told
me to watch because he felt like
Jiro, the 85-year-old sushi chef, reminded
him of me, and
I don't even like sushi, so obviously I was intriged.
I really love this film, but I was simultaneously flatered
and a bit worried that Jiro reminded Mickeleh of me.
Flatered because Jiro's crazy dedecation to sushi
has made him arguably
the best in the world at what he does. I don't think I deserve it,
but yes I am happy to be compared to that.
But it scared be because while Jiro does seem to
be happy,
it's hard to really know if he feels fulfulled by the life
that he's led,
and he also seems to have some pretty serious
regrets about not being close to his family
because of his dedication to his work.
I always thought that I wanted to be the kind
of person
who would work, and work, and work, and work at
one particular thing and become
the best that I could at that one thing. And I still
kind of do want, but at the same time
this film reminded me not to work so hard that I
forget to live as well.
Number 3: Toy Story 3. I'm pretty sure that the
original Toy Story was my first ever favorite film.
I have good memories of sitting right here in this
very spot, actually,
watching it over and over and over again on VHS.
I remember acting
it out with my little brother in front of the television, and obviously
I got my own Buzz Lightyear for Christmas too.
Then twelve years passed, and I see a trailer for
this film called Wall-E,
which I initially dismiss as just being another
animated film for kids, but then I see it
in the cinema, I fall in love with it, completely in
love with it.
I go home, I look up Pixar, the people who made the film,
I discover they're the same people who made Toy Story
my mind is blown, and instantly I'm a Pixar fanboy.
Again.
Two more years pass, and I find myself at Pixar
Studios about to see a preview screening of
Toy Story 3 before the film has even finished and
after introducing it,
the director of the film, Lee Unkrich, turns around
and says, "Hey Charlie, my kids love your videos."
I don't know if I really learned any lessons from the
whole thing other than that just
sometimes things can come full circle in ways that
you do not expect them to, and when they do
it can be unbelievably cool.
Number 4: Kiki's Delivery Service. So a teenage boy,
relating to Spider-Man. Maybe that's not much of a leap,
but finding myself at 20-years-old relating very
heavily to a 13-year-old animated witch
with a talking cat was slightly more
unexpected for me.
Mild spoilers: in the film, Kiki, who loves to fly on her broom,
leaves home and sets up a delivery service,
and so the thing that she loves, flying, becomes her job.
As a result of this, Kiki then finds herself losing her
ability to fly and it's only through an effort to
try and get her powers back that she realizes she
has to find a new purpose in order
to be able to fly again. Basically, the film is a
perfect analogy for writer's block
and for what it's like to lose your passion for
something that you used to love.
I'm a massive fan of Studio Ghibli's films. If you haven't heard of them,
they are basically the Japanese equivalent of Disney,
and Kiki's always been my favorite film of theirs simply
because of that lesson it taught me about creativity,
which it taught me at a time when I really needed to
hear it and when
nobody in real life seemed to be giving me the
answer I was looking for. I had to find it in a movie.
Number 5: Shaun of the Dead. Every single film
that I have ever watched has
in some way contributed to me wanting to be a
filmmaker, but if I had to pick one
that tipped me over the edge, it would undoubtedly be
Shaun of the Dead. This might not come as a massive surprise
given that, like Shaun of the Dead, every film I've
made so far has been a
low-budget British comedy that plays off of a bigger genre
and given that Edgar Wright's movies
are a massive influence on many aspiring
filmmakers my age, almost to the point
of cliché, but I can't deny my influences just 'cause
they're the same as everyone else's.
It's such a brilliant film, it is so well written and
well shot, but the key for me
was that it was those things while simultaneously
being low-budget and British,
and it was thinking about those things that made
me realize that filmmaking is
a real-life thing that I can actually do if I wanted to,
and now I am.
So, yay. That's my list. Thanks for watching.
Goodbye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Thank you for watching. Here's my most recent
video in case you missed it.
I was inspired to make this video after seeing
Mickeleh's videos on this topic,
and he, in turn, was inspired by Jon D. Barker,
so do check out their videos as well,
and if you'd like to do your own personally
significant films, then feel free to.
You're allowed. It's your life. Do what you wish.
But don't murder or all of the other illegal things.
But you can make video responses-- no you can't even do
that anymore, can you? I guess just don't do anything then.
Heh heh...
SILENCE